Voiceover: What I want to do in this video
is discuss what it means to be a metal,
or metallic in nature.
First, let's just think about the metals
that we encounter in everyday life,
or based on our experience
the things that we
associate with being a metal.
The elements that really
jump out at us as metals
or we always refer to,
"Hey, that's a metal,
"or that's metallic,"
are things like iron,
or nickel, or copper, or silver, or gold,
or aluminum, or at least for me,
these are the ones that
immediately pop out.
I've seen these things before,
and they all feel like metals to me,
but also think about what's
true about these things
and as we'll see many other elements
on the periodic table that give them
this metallic nature.
What do we associate with
having a metallic nature?
One is that these things can be shiny.
These things tend to be shiny.
There's kind of a gloss
when light shines on it.
They're not just kind of a matte color.
They look metallic literally.
That's sometimes a word
that's used for it.
It has a metallic shininess to it.
Another thing that we associate with it
is that they tend to be fairly dense.
If I take a metal, a block of a metal
and if I drop it into water,
I imagine that sinking, not floating
on top of the water.
We also imagine them having a very high
melting point, that they tend to be solid
at room temperature.
Solid at room temperature.
As we'll see, this is true of all metals
except for one of them which is mercury
which is shiny but at room temperature
as you might be familiar
is in its liquid form.
Now the other things that
I associate with a metal
is that I can make things out of them.
I can bend them and shape
them in different ways.
I think of aluminum foil.
I can bend it.
It's not just going to crack.
I can bend it and put it
into different shapes.
Even things like iron it might take
a lot of pressure to do it,
but they're bendable, they're malleable,
and definitely things like
gold and silver and copper
you can actually mold into
different types of jewelry.
If you put pressure on it,
it's more likely to bend than crack
and just kind of shear off.
So let's put malleability.
They're malleable.
The other thing I associate with metals
is that they conduct electricity well.
Conduct electricity.
A place that you'll see metal in your life
is if you open up your electronics
you'll see wires that might
be made out of copper,
or you might have components that are made
out of other metals like gold, or silver,
or whatever else.
Given that these are
some of the properties
that we associate with metals,
let's think about what's happening
at the atomic level to give these elements
these properties.
The way I think about it let's just
go with copper for a second.
Let's just imagine a block of copper
at the atomic level.
Let's say this is one copper nucleus
right over there,
and it has its sea of electrons.
It has its sea of electrons,
or not its sea of electrons.
It has all of its electrons
in their various orbitals.
We'll talk about sea of
electrons in a second,
but this is kind of its cloud of electrons
I should say.
So this is electron cloud.
The electrons are just
jumping around in this cloud.
It's really a probability density,
or there's kind of a certain probability
that could be at any point in that cloud.
Let's imagine a big solid piece of copper.
You would have a bunch of these.
You would have a bunch
of these all together,
all forming the solid.
What allows metals to be malleable,
to do things like conduct electricity
which is the movement of electrons,
is essentially that they're very willing
to share electrons with each other.
By sharing electrons, so you can imagine
this is one copper atom
and that's another,
let's say they're sharing some electrons,
that's what allows the electricity
or this flow of electrons to happen.
If these electrons are loosely bound,
then if you put a potential
difference of voltage,
let's say that you put
a potential difference
so that this side is more negative,
and then this side is more positive,
then the electrons are going to want
to get away from the negative charge,
and move towards the positive charge.
If they're relatively freely bound,
they can kind of move from one cloud
to the next.
You kind of end up having
what's often called
a sea of electrons.
Let me write that down.
You have a sea of
electrons which would make
this conductive and that's why you see
so much wire made out of copper.
The sea of electrons is also what
makes it malleable.
If someone on this side were to put
a lot of pressure this way,
and on that side put a
lot of pressure that way,
things that are rigid
would just kind of crack
and break, right, would
just break right over there,
but because you have the sea of electrons
it allows it to be malleable.
This part might just
bend down a little bit,
that part might bend up,
but they're not going
to, the metallic bond
is not going to break.
Given that this metallic nature
really comes from the willingness
of these atoms to share
electrons with each other,
to create the sea of electrons,
I encourage you to pause this video
and think about which atoms
on the periodic table,
or which elements are
more likely to do that,
to share electrons with
others and with each other.
Really, this is the same principle
that we thought about ionization energy,
and electronegativity.
So pause the video.
I'm assuming you've had a go at it.
So which elements are most likely
to share electrons?
We've already seen that
if we're on the left side
of the periodic table of elements,
Group One for example,
they only have one valence electron.
It would be very hard for them
to get enough electrons to
complete that outer shell.
If they get rid of that
one valence electron,
they can go to a more stable state.
They really want to give away electrons,
and the ones over here, they're so close
if we talk about the halogens,
they're one electron away from completing
their outer shell.
They're greedy. They want
to hog these electrons.
They tend to be electronegative.
The noble gases, they're done.
They definitely don't
want to share electrons
with anyone.
They're kind of in a very stable state.
Now, the other thing
that we've talked about
is as we go down a group,
our atoms are getting larger,
and larger, and larger.
So the outermost, that 55th electron
in cesium is much more loosely bound
because it's further away than say
the third electron in lithium.
So just as we saw as the elements
in this bottom left have a
very low ionization energy.
It doesn't take much energy to remove
an electron from them,
these are the ones that are most likely
to share electrons,
and these actually have the
highest metallic nature.
So high metallic, high metallic nature.
The ones on the top right,
these are going to be the opposite.
They're very unlikely to share electrons.
They're very electronegative.
They have a very high ionization energy.
They have a low metallic nature.
I could imagine some things are popping
into your brain at this point.
We started thinking of the elements
that in our everyday life
we associate with metals,
but what I'm saying is
that these things over
have an even higher metallic nature,
but what about something like calcium.
Every day what I imagined
when I typically,
or when a lot of people imagine calcium,
they think of kind of a chalky,
a white chalky substance, very rigid,
not very malleable, not very good,
not very shiny, not very good
at conducting electricity.
Based on what I just told you,
this would have a higher metallic nature
than something like aluminum.
What you have to remind yourself
is that what you see is
not actually pure calcium,
that kind of chalky thing.
That's calcium carbonate.
Pure calcium, actually, this is actually
a picture of pure calcium.
It is shiny. It does have
these metallic properties.
The general trend here
is that all of these,
these are very high in metallic nature,
and these are very low metallic nature
which also makes you probably realize
while most of the periodic table
is a metal of some form.
If aluminum is a metal,
and all of these things have a higher,
have a higher metallic nature
than all of this stuff,
all of this stuff are metals,
and that is the case.
The S block, the D block, the F block,
these are all metals.
Then a good chunk of the P block,
a good chunk of the P block
are considered metals,
and then these are kind of
sometimes referred to as metalloids,
Only this section of the periodic table
is not considered a metal.
That makes sense.
Nobel gases, they are gases.
They don't, they're not very reactive.
they don't bond so they don't form
kind of a structure that can even do
this type of thing.
These other ones over here even carbon
when it is formed a lattice,
it does not conduct electricity well.
It tends to not be so malleable
if you think about
something like a diamond,
or if you think about, well, a diamond
might be the best example of that.
Anyway, hopefully this gives you a sense
of metallic nature and the trends
in the periodic table.
High metallic nature, and
as you go to the top right,
lower and lower metallic nature.